hi everyone it's jerry this is game four
from the 2021 fide world chess
championship match between
birthday boy magnus carlson who turned
31 today and ian nepomnichi
going into game four we're level one and
a half points a piece let's see what
happened in game four
opening wise it's e4 this time by
carlson no d4 as in game 2
replies e5
no roy lopez
instead
black goes for the petrov's defense
russian game
knight takes e
no knight takes e4 here
queen e2 would be problematic
so it's important to flick in first d6
drive the knight back and only then take
on e4
d4 d5 symmetrical structure
most invasive piece right now
to white
is this black knight on e4 so some
pressure applied to it
some development for black
keeping a watchful eye over this night
jump
castles for both sides
and now the beginning of
undermining the knight first with c4
trying to remove the defender that's
maintained
more pressure on the knight
it's defended
and now queen to b3
now during the live stream a move i
pointed out here that's
sometimes
common not in this exact position but
this idea
will often be to me
an idea will often be to meet queen b3
with queen b6
this would not be a good way to defend
the threat on b7
why well if queen b6 what white can play
is queen c2 and white is doing very well
here
because
there's now
not only additional pressure on e4
but there's the threat of c5
with the fork
if black follows with getting out of
that fork idea let's say returning the
queen
to its home square
after knight c3
what to do with this knight on e4
the big issue is that the knight cannot
easily
well it can't be defended
and if it grabs the knight on c3 we
don't recapture
we take the bishop on f5 and now this
knight is stuck
has no better than to go to e4 and white
will soon pick up a pawn
so my point here queen b3 cannot
be met with queen b6
what is played queen d7
watches over b7
and d5 indirectly
the light's unable to take twice on this
square because of this trick
capturing on h2 with check and there
goes the queen
so from here we have knight c3
knight takes knight
bishop takes bishop
queen takes bishop
and not the queen recapturing instead
it's the b pawn strengthening white
center somewhat and well the primary
reason i believe we're still keeping
pressure on b7
b6
c takes d
c takes d
and this knight right about now probably
has its
uh has its eyes on the c4 square
i really like to get these moves in this
is a great outpost square for the black
knight
so white interferes with that
queen b5 you can't get there so easily
black wants that though
and so offers a queen exchange wants
knight c6 a5
once more in a spot
indirectly defending d5 because of the
trick on h2
a4
white saying if we're going to have a
queen exchange at least help out my rook
black's okay with that
takes the queen
and now this guy right here
is backward
timely move right now if by black
a5
if you don't make this move right now it
could be the case this pawn may
struggle you may you may have some idea
to target it along the a file form a
battery
so
a5 right now it could be captured
b takes a on poisson and this is
something i'd like to touch on
different structure that can surface
in the game we had knight h4
if white goes ahead and captures on a6
this
initially to me looked appealing because
now
these two are isolated on the queen side
this guy right here on c3 isn't the
greatest it's backward but
comparing the two structures on the
queen side it tips ever so slightly
in white's favor
but
a plan black can go forward with should
this structure surface on the queen side
is rook f to b8
let's say
the white king improves or we get a
flight square in
b5
is the thing
and then b4 and we could soon have the b
and c pawns exchanged and there really
isn't
uh enough of an imbalance in the
position to go for anything
to pursue some decisive
so
that's a way forward is what i'm getting
at should white go ahead and capture on
a6 instead it remains imbalanced
we have with knight h4
white being okay with this connected
past pawn on board
and with the knight h4
white has his eyes on the d5 pawn
it's looking to get into f5 and then e3
putting pressure on that point
so
f5 is ruled out
there's also a flight square for the
king with g6
and now this knight doesn't have really
a good square so
another one is produced
g4
g6
also opens up that square white's trying
to extract the most out of each move
however
having the pawn on
g4 instead of g3
uh can play an important role
in this game
g4 what is it looking to do primarily
open up g2 but looking more long term
at some point it has the possibility to
go to g5 and scare away knight on f6
a knight on f6 can be is probably the
most convenient defender of
the d5 pawn
so let's get some moves in here first
it's knight d7
knight g2
rook on
f to c8 and instead of defending this
pawn directly white goes in
for the d5 pawn
white saying with this next move bishop
f4
i'm ok if you take my c pawn i want to
get
your d5 pawn in exchange
so
you don't have time to take on c3 its
bishop takes bishop in this position
and after the knight recaptures you'll
know
that because this pawn in this position
is on g4
instead of g3
black would not have this move
move 22 knight f6
this is not a
stable square for the knight
knight f6 could be met with g5
and then knight takes pawn and this
knight is
quite as one upon and is now out of
control
ready to land a fork
in multiple ways
so
a nice detail here regarding the
position of the g pawn
this is ruled out if this guy's still on
g3 knight f6 is perfect it's best
okay from this point on we have rook gt
rook takes c3 knight takes d5 so now
there's two passers still some imbalance
is present on the queen side
rook is hit
doesn't have very many choices rook b3
and rook d3 are considered best
black goes for rook d3
i think that makes the most sense
this is a pawn that can
be a bit scary
it is a passer
so the rook is behind it in fact both
black rooks are ideally placed i would
say
behind the past pawns
from here rook e7 there is only one move
this knight cannot be defended
because there are these tricks
where you can go ahead and take
and then land the fork
that square is available to the knight
so the knight has to move
knight f8 only move
this you would just be asking for
trouble a check a pin
so knight f8 it is
trim here knight f6 king g7
knight e8 check king g8
and the game continues
with d5 this is how white defends the
pawn
not directly indirectly again with this
id of a four
this guy's passed this guy is passed
they both get running
a4
knight f6 check
king g7 g5
and from here a3
now what exactly to do in this position
on this move 30 for white
uh if we continue on this path of simply
pushing our past pawns
so light on move
if you go forward with d6 this move is
not without its issues
uh
the main issue with d6 is that you give
up a really big square
to this knight
so after d6
black would be able to improve the
knight
and look what would be happening with
the knight on e6
the knight puts pressure on the g pawn
the knight helps assist in controlling
the promotion square
and
if knight eight is to follow there's now
a new square
well whether or not the knight makes use
of e8 because the knight is on e6 and
not on f8 the king has access to f8
so if ever a check
king f8 is a nice reply
approaching the white pieces pressure on
the rook one step closer to helping
support or defend against
white's past pawn
so black black gains
quite a bit
if
the e6 square is available to the black
knight
if instead of d6 white plays h4
securing at least g5
you know if a little bit later knight e6
is there
you don't have to tend to the pressure
on g5 well
there could be a downside connected with
h4
black can first of all play h5
fix the h4 pawn there is no time to take
on poisson because the knight would fall
h4 would be fixed potentially
targeted
by either rook
and
there's also a square on h7
so that this knight can maybe challenge
the knight on f6
so
carlson was not able to justify
continuing
play basically he
was kind of going back and forth
really uh
trying to look for something here you
could see by the clock times
he has about 67 minutes in this position
and yeah he put a pretty good think in
there
35 minutes he was trying for something
but in the end
nothing was there
it wasn't clear to him he really
couldn't justify going for more i mean
if we do a piece
comparison
we can say yeah the white knight is
better than the black knight
but what about this guy on a1
there's no way it's better than these
two rooks who again are ideally placed
behind
both past pawns
couldn't justify going for more so in
the end
decided on
inserting these checks and having
another
peaceful result
draw in this game
for
by repetition of position
so
we remain
level uh this turned out to be about a
three hour
game so we didn't quite meet that first
time control where the players get an
extra hour at move 40.
we remain level it only ever uh gets
more
tense
sure if you go ahead and continue
drawing your games well
yeah
you're eventually gonna run out there's
only 14 classical games so somebody's
going to break or we're just going to
see some more games in the end if it
does happen to go to tie breaks but
we're a long ways
away from that
let's have a look at
the quality of play here let's have a
look at the tail of the tape on this one
and we'll see that yet again
these guys are registering a single
digit for average senti pawn loss
the lower the number the better
and yeah pretty much a flat liner again
super high quality play
and
in the end what is it seven average semi
pawn loss for team white team carlson
and a six for team nepomnichi
so we'll see what happens in game five
feel free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below hope you enjoyed it and maybe took
a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you